Salutare tuturor și bine ați revenit pe
canalul de YouTube la Pescuit cu Total
Fishing. Astăzi suntem pe zona de
frontieră în județul Călărași și o să
încercăm o partidă de pescuit la somn.
acum până în Prohibiția 2026 sunt cu
prietenul meu Claudiu și cu fratele lui.
O să stăm undeva la 36 de ore pe malul
Dunării în încercarea de a captura
câțiva somni acum cât mai apucăm până în
prohibiția și pe zona de frontieră. Doar
ce am ajuns pe locul de pescuit, primul
lucru pe care l am făcut, am căutat ceva
râme albe de pădure pentru că rămân la
părerea că râma albă de pădure în
perioada asta e cea mai bună momeală
pentru pescuitul somnului. Pe lângă râme
albe suntem pregătiți și cu niște râme
negre, iar pescuitul pe care î vom face
este un pescuit de pe mal la staționar
și vom ieși puțin și la clong. Avem
parte de două zile superbe, cu excepția
serii care urmează, unde se anunță și
ceva vânt. Momentan vremea este superbă.
Sper să vă arătăm câțiva somni frumoși
aici pe zona de frontieră în județul
Călărași. Am găsit și un loc frumos de
Campat. Zona arată foarte bine. Avem și
o adâncime de 6 7 m cu un prag destul de
abrupt și ceva cioate scufundate. Pare o
zonă ok pentru pescuitul somnului la
staționar. tot ce facem, cum pescuim,
dacă prindem ceva, doar dacă stați până
la finalul acestui video și nu uitați,
dacă nu sunteți abonați, să vă abonați
la canalul de YouTube la Pescuul Total
Fishing. Bun, acum că am reușit și noi
să ne campăm, să ne așezăm aici pe malul
Dunării, mă grăbesc pentru că ușor ușor
se înorează și se anunță și ceva vânt,
chiar furtună spre seară. Așa că vreau
să vă prezint înainte de toate tot
echipamentul și tot ansamblul cu care cu
care pescuiesc eu la somn la staționar.
Folosesc lansete Okuma Tomcad MPS 270
în lungime de 2,74 și acțiune 40 120 g.
Ele practic sunt niște lansete de
spinning heavy dedicate pentru somn,
însă eu le folosesc foarte bine în
pescuitul staționar de pe mal. Mulinetă
clasica Okuma 8K surf, o mulinetă de
8000. Iar ca și firosesc
Car Spirit Velocity XS Camu de 0.
Echipamentul pe care îl folosesc de ani
de zile. Cei care mă urmăriți știți că l
am mai tot prezentat și îl folosesc cu
succes de câțiva ani. Montura e ceva
extrem de simplu. Folosesc un plumb pară
de la Car Spirit de 150 g.
O montură tip balansoar undeva la 10 cm
deasupra plumbului. Am un nod cu care mă
mă leg de forfac. Iar forfacul este
undeva la
70 cm. O să încerc cât mai mult
pescuitul pe fund la la această ieșire.
Deci, un forfac lung de 70 cm din
fluorocarbon.
Folosesc Spirit Optimx de 0,50.
Iar cârligele pe care le folosesc sunt
niște CAT Spirit, mărimea 5/0. Sunt
niște cârlige produse de VMC pentru CAT
Spirit. De asemeni și cârligele și
fluorocarbonul le folosesc de mult timp.
Deci o montură balansoar 150 de g plumb
și un ricam de 70 cm cu cârligul Cat
Spirit pe care îl umplem cu râme negre
sau râme albe de aici din pădure.
Absolut toate produsele pe care le
folosesc or să fie puse și în descrierea
acestui videoclip cu link către magazin
și absolut toate produsele pe care le
vedeți la mine le găsiți evident la noi
la magazinul Total Fish.
Hai că avem o primă trăsătură.
Cred că poți să vii mai aproape să ne și
auzim cătă
un somn frumos.
Hai că s a spart gheața.
S a spart gheața consom frumos. La vreo
3 kg cred,
la
40 de minute de când am ajuns.
Începem bine partida.
Un somn frumușel. Hai să ți arătăm
primul somn pe anul
2026. Ne cam sparge vântul, dar e bine
că am început bine.
Hai mai aproape să arătăm și la ce l am
prins. La râme albe din pădure. Așa cum
v am spus,
e momeala preferată a lui în această
perioadă.
Slavă Domnului că avem umezeală în
pădure și putem să scoatem râme multe.
Ia uitați ce bine s a agățat.
Ce înțepătură bună.
Cârlegele de la Cat Spirit l [sforăit] a
luat foarte bine.
E bine că avem cazma la noi, deci putem
să ne procurăm momeală de aici de la
botul calului.
Și primul somn
din 2026.
Un pește
frumușel.
Nu e el cel mai mare, dar suntem doar în
startul partidei
și am început cu dreptul.
Între timp am mai avut o trăsătură, am
întârziat puțin până să înțep și peștele
s a dus într o cioată scufundată de aici
de pe zona de pescuit.
Am intrat cu barca și am reușit să luăm
un nou somn, tot așa undeva în jur de 3
kg.
Partenerul meu, Cătălin, n a reușit să
filmeze drillul până la capăt, însă
partida începe destul de bine pentru
noi, cu doi pești relativ rapid. Ușor,
ușor ne pregătim de pescuitul de noapte.
Vântul care se anunța
s a pus încă de mai devreme, dar acum a
început să bată din ce în ce mai tare.
După cei doi somotei frumoși
luați așa rapid, unul l am scos chiar cu
barca de aici, intrase într o agățătură.
N am mai avut nicio acțiune, dar
bineînțeles speranțele noastre merg merg
către pescuitul de noapte. Dacă începe
vântul și mai tare de atât, pentru că
simt că se va porni din ce în ce mai
tare, ne băgăm la corturi. Sperăm să ne
trezească cineva și în noaptea asta,
pentru că speranțele principale ale
noastre sunt pe parcursul nopții.
Încărcăm bine la înserat acum cârligele
cu râme.
Momentan ambii pești au venit la Râmă
Albă de Pădure despre care vă spuneam și
în introducere, că în opinia mea
rămâne cea mai bună momeală pentru somn
acum în perioada de primăvară din start
de sezon,
când apa încă nu este foarte caldă.
Momentan avem o apă de 11°.
Mai avem râme destule,
avem pentru toată noaptea.
Dacă le consumăm dimineață, mai tragem o
fugă în pădure, mai scoatem câteva râme.
Însă vântul începe din ce în ce mai
tare.
Ne așteptăm și la o furtună. E totuși
luna aprilie. Ce te poți aștepta de la
luna asta?
Sper să revin pe parcursul nopții cu cu
ceva frumos.
Am pregătit echipamentul pentru noapte.
Am pus aici o lansetă.
Am și o cioată aici, undeva la 15 20 de
m și am încercat s o apropii cât mai
mult de cioata aceea.
Locurile sunt destul de înguste, destul
de strimte pe zona asta și fiind și cota
mare, pescuim de aici din pădure, de
sus, dintre copaci.
Ce vedeți pe aici sunt rămășițele unui
copac rost de casturi pentru cei care
mai veniți prin sărbăticie.
Așa arată copacul rost de castori.
Au rost scoarță din el și a fost un
adevărat festin pentru ei. Aici
am aici o a doua lansetă.
Și ultima, ceva mai departe,
cam pe ultimul loc de pe zona aceasta
am pus o aici. Doar ce le am încărcat,
le am încărcat bine cu râme albe, cu
râme negre
și
vedem peste noapte. Momentan ne am pus
să gătim și noi ceva. Mai am una și la
tabără. Acolo lângă băieți pescuiesc cu
patru lansete. Am mai avut ceva
trăsături așa, dar înclin să cred că
erau pești mici care ciuguleau de râme,
mai ales că noi am băgat lansetele încă
de pe zi când era lumină.
Vedem cum continuă partida. Sperăm la
niște sprinturi pe aici, printre copacii
ăștia deși în această noapte.
Iar vizavi peisajul e splendid.
Deci dacă nu înțelegeți ce s a
întâmplat, un fitofag a sărit pe mal și
a căzut fix în înre rădăcinile asteaici.
Deci ăa e.
>> Pune mâna ca lumea în brainile că să
cadă
>> trebuie să te prinzi cu mâna după mal.
Deci n ați văzut în viață mă.
>> Deci luminam.
>> Vezi că dacă se zbante Ioane.
>> Luminam cu lanterna
>> direct în apăsare. Dă te mai pe mal.
>> Luminam cu lanterna.
>> Dă te de lângă apă de aice.
>> Luminam cu lanterna în apă și a sărit.
Omal pur și simplu
unc pare. Deci un pește prins
>> cu mâna.
>> Cu mâna după mare. Incredibil.
Ah.
la e director.
În dimineața aceasta [muzică] am
profitat de faptul că este o zi superbă.
Cuvânt spre zero, nu sunt valuri, așa că
am ieșit puțin, am încercat puțin
norocul și la clonc.
Din păcate, somnul nu s a activat încă,
nu prea reacționează. Am avut o singură
trăsătură ceva mai jos de locul de
campat, dar o trăsătură nefinalizată.
Cred că doar
a tras puțin de râme pentru că nu a fost
o trăsătură evidentă. Trăsătura a venit
la prietenul meu Claudiu. Nici n a
apucat să înțepe, dar din ce am dat și
cât am culoncănit noi pe aici, pare că
somnul încă nu s a pornit și încă nu
reacționează.
Am revenit pe mal. O să mai schimbăm o
dată lansetele pentru că toți peștii
prinși au fost prinși pe timp de zi.
Curios pentru că ne așteptam să avem
activitate și pe timp de noapte, dar pe
timp de noapte n am avut
absolut nicio trăsătură decât
întâmplarea aceasta cu acest fitofag
care a sărit pe Malas noapte din
poveștile poveștile Dunării. O să l și
oprim pentru că e specie invazivă. Cu
siguranță știți cu toții asta pentru că
pare o zonă fierbinte pentru fitofag.
Probabil că atunci când va fi vremea de
pescuit la fitofag o să încercăm și o
ieșire la fitofag pe zona aceasta pentru
că oricum în portofoliul Total Fishing
găsiți și nadă pentru fitofag. Nada
fitofag Atac o găsiți pe site ul nostru.
Am avut aici o trăsătură puternică și
văd că și la Uite acum trage. Am auzit o
de la tabără.
Din păcate e în copac
agățat.
Peștele încă acolo, dar
cred că s a agățat în cioată, în prag,
în ceva.
Prietenul meu Claudiu e plecat cu barca,
așa că tocmai l am sunat, de am și oprit
filmarea să vină să încercăm să l
scoatem cu barca, dar peștele e acolo.
Hai că nu e mare, dar
Bravo! Bă, nu e mare, dar la
>> Da, a ieșit în
>> Nu e mare. Are 2 kg. Dar e muncit rău de
tot peștele ăsta.
Ia uite, are burta plină. E mare.
>> Da.
Nu e mare. Are vreo 2 kg și burta plină.
Mulțumesc lui Claudiu și lui Cătălin că
au venit de la cioată să mă ajute.
A fost agățat bine, bine de tot,
dar fără grabă, cu un pic de muncă, cu
un pic de migală, un somn muncit, scos
din ceasă.
Chiar frumos.
Peștele nu i foarte mare, dar aventura
de prindere a lui
e o reușită totală.
Uite ce burtă are. Vezi? E mâncat. E
foarte bine mâncat. Știi?
Am avut o nouă trăsătură frumoasă.
Doar că n am reușit din nou să prind
trăsătura pentru că băieții iar au
plecat cu barca
și am fost la tabără să iau minciogul.
Încă un somn.
Am reușit să iau încă unul frumușel.
De fiecare dată când pleacă băieții de
la tabără, am și eu trăsături.
Am mai luat unul frumos. [icnet]
[oftat]
Tot așa, la vreo două k parcă sunt frați
toți. [sforăit]
Și din nou la râmă albă.
[oftat]
Vă arăt și râmele imediat.
Râmă albă de aici din pădure.
Un nou somn.
A, e o mrenă, mă, n aici
e ăsta.
Mersi.
A
pe lângă somn a venit și o mreană
frumoasă.
Chiar frumoasă.
Ia uite o cum stă cu râmele albe în
gură.
Se vede, Cătălin?
>> Se vede.
Stai cuminte că ți dau drumul oricum.
Uite și omreană frumoasă.
O s și eliberăm imediat.
Bah
Captura partidei la somn e acest frumos
sângere. Până la urmă nu e Novac. Mi s a
mai spus mie că sunt un pescar norocos.
Acum încep să cred și eu.
Un sânger de vreo 5 6 kg care azi noapte
ne plimbam cu lanternele pe aici pe
lângă mal. Voiam să schimbăm lansetele.
A sărit pe mal singur. A sărit o dată în
apă, după care a doua săritură a fost
direct pe mal.
Am stabilit cu băieții să l și oprim.
Oricum e specie invazivă și totodată am
stabilit și cu ei să încercăm o partidă
dedicată pentru el la toamnă.
Cu acest cadru și închei acest video.
Mulțumim că ne ați urmărit. Rămâneți în
continuare pe toate rețelele magazinului
Total Fishing. O să ieșim. Sper să mai
fac o ieșire până în prohibiție. Sper să
ajung și la scrumbie. Deci, rămâneți
alături de noi la Pescuit cu Total
Fishing. Fire întinse tuturor în 2026.
Yeah.